what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so it's been a little while since
we've done really Hickman's i'm
sorry/not Hickman we'll talk about him
so it has record in this video but it's
been a little while since we've done
Jeff lemierre's old man Logan the reason
why is because we've just been waiting
for stories to wrap up we don't remember
these come out monthly so a little bit
takes like six months for a story to
finish which is kind of crazy in this
case it only takes three because this is
only three issues long but this is
basically returned to the wastelands now
this is basically leading up to Jeff
Lemire story about old man Logan where
he has to go back and revisit all the
most significant moments of his life and
that's designed for the purpose I think
to kind of go back and retell his origin
because remember you have the old man
Logan story but aside from you know the
way he was dressed in a few of the
little tidbit so we've got me here and
there we don't really know the full life
of that version of Logan we just kind of
know that he was part of the x-men he
was basically tricked into killing them
all and that set off the old man Logan
story and so because of that I think
were going to kind of go back or at
least we're going to you know we're
gonna have a Geoffrey miracle I can give
us all this old stuff but what this does
is it initially just kind of picks up in
the wasteland keep in mind you know that
was the whole name of the area that that
old man Logan was in that's the old man
Logan area was really just like the
wasteland it was really kind of a cool
story because what it did is it gave us
or it gives us this whole thing of him
trying to figure out where he's at and
how he got here because member his mind
is kind of in disarray that's a big
thing about this right now is for old
man Logan he had you know been tricked
into killing the x-men and then he had
tried to make his way after killing the
Incredible Hulk family taking Bruce
Banner jr. as his own son and then that
led into the whole Hickman Fantastic
Four which had the idea that you know
hope Bruce Banner a junior would go on
to [ __ ] we fight Galactus kill Galactus
in the news his body which would be
transported back to the modern day will
get out here a little bit so there are a
lot of things that went on with the
character of Bruce Banner jr. and with
old man Logan himself and so the idea is
that he's basically bouncing back and
forth and he's trying to figure out how
he ended up back in the wasteland so
what this does is this coincides with
the modern day and that's what he's
trying to figure out is which one's real
is he really in the wastelands or is he
really in the modern day but in terms of
where he's out
now he's actually inside of a space
station the crazy thing is he's
basically been sitting here in order to
figure out what happened to Alpha Flight
and the reason why is because no one
knows what happened to them keep in mind
and all-new all-different marvel were
prior to the events of secret wars Alpha
Flight was just like Canada's superhero
team that nobody cared about and all-new
all-different marvel they're basically a
part of sword which is a sentient world
observation and response department
designed to basically monitor threats
from other worlds across the universe
and Alpha Flight is still a group nobody
cares about but they're part they're not
part of Canada they're basically part of
the ongoing Carol Danvers Captain Marvel
story ah yeah back anyway um so what we
end up doing here is eventually find out
that within the space station that the
brood seemed to have simply gone awry
now but those guys who don't know the
brood are this alien race and Marvel
that are basically the xenomorph that's
essentially what they are from the Alien
franchise that's basically how they
exist nine times out of ten when the
brood are procreating they basically
plan an embryo in the body of their host
and then the embryo emerges and the host
basically dies it's just like the
xenomorph the difference is that
sometimes the brood will turn people
into into members of the brief by the
literally ticket take a human being and
basically transmogrify them so that they
become a member of the brood race itself
that having a storm if I remember
correctly I haven't do a few other
people here and there they do that every
once a while especially if that person
has an ability that the brood want but
what we do is we find out that again
because it's bruised this we run a lie
the brood don't usually take prisoners
and so if the brood have gone crazy they
basically showed up on this space
station that Alpha Flight was sent to
investigate and nobody's heard back then
there's a really good chance that off a
flight is basically killed off not only
that we actually end up picking up with
with Logan when he meets with Danielle
cage now again Daniel cage is the
daughter of Jessica Jones and Luke Cage
which tells us that she survived the
whole experience with everybody kind of
going crazy and everything you know
going absolutely nuts but the idea here
is that as far as Daniel Cage is
concerned the baby was left with her
Bruce Payne or jr. was left with her to
take care of but somewhere along the
line baby's gone and no one knows where
it's gone to and so again this kind of
bounces back and forth it kind of goes
back and forth in a sense that sasquatch
one of the members of the brood has sort
of gone crazy inside of this facility
and this indicates that the brood of
taking control of him and so again
Logan's trying to figure out everything
that's going on but ultimately he ends
up coming across pucks now park was a
long-term member of Alpha Flight in a
Benno
huge ally of wool brain for quite some
time until again this is Jeff Lemire
giving up these little goodies this is
Jeff Lemire giving a few little tidbits
curling up but the history of old man
Logan seems to be almost exactly like
the history of the main Marvel Universe
rule of rain before he died and so talk
being part of Alpha Flight indicates to
us that his version of old man Logan
probably served as part of Alpha Flight
in the old man Logan universe but with
tuck being here he's kind of like this
guy that's going to guide Logan through
you know basically saying hey man like
the brood have gone crazy everything
went awry no one really knows what's
going on here all we know is or at least
all I know is that everybody seems to be
being killed the problem with this is
that in the midst of Logan talking to
talking to puck suddenly Logan is
basically jettisoned out of the airlock
he's literally just kind of yanked away
but then he has these last recollection
that he remembers and this is where the
story starts to get back to the same
state of normalcy again Jeff Lemire is
kind of going nuts when it comes to the
old man Logan stores that's why I loved
him but he kind of goes crazy here what
happened is Logan begins to kind of jump
back and forth a little faster than he
was before
where's regards to the wastelands and
and what's going on here but what we
what we have is Logan you know back in
the wastelands investigating everything
that's going on and coming across what
seems to be basically the spirit of ken
king the Conqueror begins to talk to him
and Kane the Conqueror says somebody
screwed up time remember Kenya is this
guy you know Nathaniel which is a scar
that basically tries to use time to his
advantage to conquer time itself to
really kind of make himself the absolute
ruler of all existence and so because of
this if King says somebody messed with
time then the indication is that things
played out like this when the old man
Logan story ended and old man Logan had
taken Bruce Banner jr. and left him with
Daniel Cage the way things were supposed
to go was that Bruce Banner jr. would
eventually grow up he would join forces
with a handful of the remaining
superheroes or those newly emerging
superheroes after all the villains were
defeated and after their empire was torn
down 500 years in the future the earth
would essentially be dying Galactus
would show up to consume the dying earth
Bruce Banner jr. and his guys would
fight off Galactus they would kill him
and then use the power cosmic to
basically send themselves into the past
which picks up with Hitman's Fantastic
Four that's how things were supposed to
happen somebody messed with time
somebody screwed things up and instead
of that being the case what is up
happening is Bruce Banner jr. becomes a
guy called the warlord basically just
like like the maestro from the from the
old Incredible Hulk stories
the wasteland old man Logan is basically
facing off against what is essentially a
maestro against this son of a view
Incredible Hulk at the same time back in
the normal real world that can you know
back here in a in the space station he's
being told by puck the brood have killed
everyone there's no one left everybody
seems to be dead only that cluck himself
is being overcome by the brood attack
because there's just so many of them and
so when is it happening here is gene
gray suddenly makes her appearance and
it looks like Jean Grey has been
overtaken by the brood now that's
exactly what's confirmed here by old man
Logan that Jean Grey has been taken over
by the brood race itself and the reason
why this matters is because the brood
can now use the mind of Jean Grey for
all kinds of crazy things but with
regards to old man Logan she's the
reason why he's having all these
illusions where he's being yanked back
and forth and he's basically travelling
back to the wastelands and he's in the
modern day because it's Jean Grey just
messing with his mind none of the stuff
that we're seeing here in the wastelands
is real none of that stuff is true the
only thing that is true the only thing
that is real is the space station and
old man Logan trying to defeat all these
members of the brute but it's cool
because he keeps giving me a little bit
of flashback and it's really just him
being haunted by the ghost of its past
the fact that he killed the x-men still
haunts him the fact that he left roost
and her junior was Daniel Cage and has
no idea whatever came of him still
haunts old man Logan these are things
that still play a major role in how he
views the world well his underlying goal
while the main thing that he's focusing
on is to make sure that the old man
Logan story never actually comes to
fruition which is to say the villains
never basically rise up and attack all
the superheroes and kill them all the
idea is that because Jean Grey is
basically making him relive all these
things the idea is that once he frees
her and once the brooder basically
brought down the Oh Jean Grey uses a
hive mind of the brood to incapacitate
them or old man Logan says I have to go
back I have to go back to the wasteland
I have to go back to my universe I have
to go back and I have to find out what
happened to Bruce Payne or jr. I have to
find out what happened to that kid
because for Logan for only Logan it's
all unfinished business and again this
was really just a pre Lee this is just
kind of a quick little story that's
thrown in here for the purpose of
setting the stage for Road to the
wastelands which again will take him
back to all that stuff all that old man
Logan something that's actually
something I'm really really excited
about I'm really excited to revisit
the old man Logan universe because I
feel like what we only really got up to
this point or just like these little
things peppered in we have what Mark
Miller wrote we have you know Brian
Michael Bendis when he wrote during
Secret Wars and we have Jeff lemierre's
or man Logan and that's it we have those
three runs if we haven't seen it there
it doesn't exist and so if what I'm
thinking is a jump lemierre's going to
go back and he's basically going to give
us the whole story of old man Logan the
whole of his experiences everything that
he's ever been through and he'll
basically give us the chronological
origin of its character that's what I'm
hoping we get I don't know if that will
be true or not but if you guys are near
here to comics explain make sure you
guys with the sub-12 become part of the
rob forth you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and leave a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think about old man Logan the art I
think is absolutely incredible with the
stories really good - it's just Jeff
Lemire loves to bounce around he loves
to mess with us when we're going through
and reading these stories it's fun to
see it's funny to see but it's also kind
of crazy at the same time but anyway
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end and I will catch you all in it
[Music]